[Music]
welcome back to Sweetwater Secrets River
babes
I'm your holidays loving host Liana
Galera look how cute the tree is and
this is your preview show for episode
209 chapter 22 Silent Night deadly night
and this is also going to be the winter
finale of Riverdale season two which
means that this is the last new episode
of the year but don't be upset because
here is a holiday fun fact this was the
episode that I was on set for you guys
so today I'm going to be gifting you
with a behind the scenes sneak peek of
the episode and showing you what Archie
gives Betty for Christmas spoiler alert
it's super sweet but I know that some of
you won't be pleased
so I also asked KJ Appa his thoughts on
the barchi gift and what he really
thinks of all the social media shipper
wars so get excited for that but before
I stock your stuffings with riverdale
goodies let's take a look at some of the
comments that you guys left me after
watching episode 208 now most of you are
majorly hating on all of the
relationship shockers and I don't blame
you but did anyone think that Betty's
serpent dance 4 jug was strip tastic
here's what you had to say alright guys
now and xoxo 1:30 said hisses -
basically the entire episode Betty a 16
year old doing the striptease in front
of a bunch of adult men no thanks
I'm so mad about barchi and bug head
breaking up and I'm really mad about the
fact that Betty and Archie are going to
get together I can't even think of any
kisses damn girl but on the flip side
Yasmin controla wrote no hate but I
disagree with her histah buddies dance I
get the she's 16 and her mom was in the
room but her intentions were to protect
and look after Jughead and look into a
way different side of Betty than usual
it wasn't the best thing to do but I'm
happy that she's letting herself be dark
Betty for a little bit okay I get your
point there girl meanwhile Chloe Baker
was all about the shipper shade saying I
don't think I'll ever get past var chi
and bug head hisses - barchi i think
their greatest friends but no as a
couple and kisses to Betty's hair being
down and Jughead without his beanie man
they have beautiful hair and imagine
what their babies would look like
and Esther Victoria added if we can't
have bug head I say Veronica for the win
yes cosine and lastly zo tiga wrote wait
Leanna was on the Riverdale set way
before this so just she know who the
black hood is I'll never tell but
actually really don't know who the black
hood is but I do now the episode 209 is
going to be filled with Christmas chaos
so let's take a look at the promo to see
what Satan I mean Santa has in store for
us Merry Christmas thank you we're still
friends I don't want things to be forced
between us that's okay time for being
daddy's little girl is over she deserves
to know the truth this is the part where
we stopped a black hood right now I need
you with me
I know where this ends
death oh my gosh that looks insane but
can we focus on this Christmas miracle
we finally have a sense of time in this
show let's just take a moment to put
this all into perspective now it's been
only about six months since Jason
blossoms death on the 4th of July
and if Riverdale high starts in
September that means it's been only four
ish months since Veronica moved to town
that's a whole lot of drama for such a
short amount of time especially for
Sheryl blossom all right guys in just
six months
her brother was murdered her father
committed suicide she tried to take her
own life she burned her house down was
nearly sexually assaulted and she's
dealing daily with a heartless monster
of a mother so for those of you who are
hating on her crazy new obsession with
Josie I say we just let her have her
moment but in tonight's episode you guys
I was on set for the scene where the
entire Riverdale gang gets together and
unwraps their Secret Santa presents it's
so cute and Archie
just so happens to pull Betty's name now
you guys he gives her a really sweet
gift it's a read-along album that the
two used to listen to together when they
were little kids and it gives her all
the feels now are you bug head and
barchi fans freaking out not to worry
KJ APPA had a feeling that was gonna
happen so take a look at what he told me
about the scene christmas is here Happy
Holidays to KJ my red sweater on
and we we got to see in the b-roll that
Archie gives Betty a very sentimental
gift oh yeah how do you think the fans
were gonna react to seeing that
maybe not too happy I'd say the bucket
fans might not be heavy but if they're
confident by Kidd Hamptons and they've
got nothing to worry about
the barchi fans are gonna think they're
quite nice it's a quite nice gift
yeah the few bocce fans that are out
they will think that it's pretty good
thank you do you see a lot of the ship
earnest out there on your social media
do pay attention to that at all I don't
I really don't to be honest yeah I try
and try and not to look at it yeah you
just go with what the writing tells you
go with it yeah yeah I think that is
very smart of KJ to say out of the
shipper Wars especially after fans
watched tonight's episode yes oh yes
things happen now that does it for this
week's preview episode of Sweetwater
secrets now you guys tune into our after
show once you watch episode 209 chapter
22 Silent Night deadly night for some
behind the scenes scoop from Cole
Sprouse Lilly Reinhardt and Vanessa
Morgan now as always guys please give
this video a like share it with your
Riverdale loving friends and subscribe
to e t--'s youtube channel so you never
miss an episode of sweet butter secrets
I follow Lilla love you river babes and
I'll see you after the episode bye
[Music]
you